Втекти від світу на гору Афон.
Звільнитися від суєти, тривог, нескінченних чвар.
Православні ченці з Греції, України, Росії та інших країн
живуть і моляться тут уже понад 1000 років. Принаймні так було дотепер.
Віднедавна чернечому братству загрожує конфлікт, що спалахнув за межами Афона.
Цей корабель ходить сюди щодня.
Однак на берег дозволено ступати лише чоловікам.
Судна пристають в Урануполі - рибальському селищі неподалік Афона.
Тут приїжджі отримують візу для відвідування монастирів
і тут же купують квитки на катер до обителі.
Серед паломників - тільки греки і росіяни.
Вони засмучені, адже їхні патріархи - у сварці через Україну.
Константинопольсь виступає за незалежну Українську церкву,
однак РПЦ цей варіант не влаштовує. Більш того:
тепер РПЦ заборонила своїм священикам
спільні богослужіння із Вселенським патріархатом. Зокрема і на Афоні.
- Ми не можемо не послухатися церкву-матір, тому
просто молитимемося, просто відвідуватимемо святі місця. Ну, а служити будемо вдома.
З Урануполі до бухти Афона - Дафні - ще
близько години на катері. На борту - греки, слов'яни,
американці й араби. Миряни і церковний люд.
Їдемо у грецький монастир Сімонопетра.
Значна частина безцінних ікон і святинь у грецьких монастирях - подарунки російських еліт.
Царська Росія століттями підтримувала Грецію в часи Османської імперії.
Але навіть коли йдеться про різні православні церкви,
місцеві ченці кажуть, що вони єдині питаннях віри.
А ситуація з українською церквою, на їхню думку,
пов'язана передусім з політикою і владою.
Тут кажуть, що національність ченців на Афон
ніколи не мала великого значення.
У монастирі Святого Пантелеймона живуть російські та українські схимники.
Зустрічаємо там православного священика з Чехії.
Що він думає про церковну суперечку?
- Звідси також линуть посилені молитви до Господа,
щоб Господь влаштував життя православної церкви так, як потрібно.
Але чи мають російські священники правити служби спільно з грецькими?
- Кожен повинен чинити по совісті.
Голос совісті – це голос Божий.
Для продовження подорожі потрібен ще один човен.
Дві години чекаємо біля каси, але зрештою потрапляємо на борт.
На кораблі зустрічаємо українських і російських прочан, які також планують відвідати монастир.
Тепер вони розмірковують, чи брати участь у богослужіннях на Афоні.
- Це особисте питання кожного християнина
і в цій всій ситуації кожен для себе сам вирішує.
Але якщо каже владика, то, відповідно, для людей,
які перебувають на службі в РПЦ, мабуть,
це пряма вказівка, яку слід виконувати.
А для мирян це питання віри та душі.
Нарешті дістаємося берега.
Їдемо до російського ченця, який мешкає у віддаленому районі Афона.
Дорогою можна побачити, з чого живуть чернечі громади:
лісове господарство та виноробство. Значна частина
з 20 великих монастирів Афона переповнені.
Дедалі більше ченців стають відлюдниками.
Ось і отець Микола понад 30 років живе на Афоні.
Він шкодує про конфлікт між Константинополем та  Москвою,
але перед камерою вирішує промовчати.
Повертаємося назад до Урануполі, де зустрічаємо Діно.
Раніше він був водієм таксі в Дюссельдорфі, тепер
реставрує монастир і вирощує оливковий сад.
- Між греками та росіянами - тисячолітня дружба!
І вона й надалі залишається тісною. Те, що
роблять політики, що чинять обидва патріархи,
я навіть не слухаю всього цього. Мені байдуже.
Під час суперечки через Україну миряни і ченці
намагаються зосередитися на позитиві в цій складній ситуації.
Вони шукають примирення і виступають
проти розпалювання національної ворожнечі.